en el Limbo fronterizo y en precarias
condiciones ya tenemos aquí desde el
domingo
la crisis migratoria en la zona
limítrofe entre chile y Perú siga
grabándose a medida que aumenta la
desesperación de los cientos de
migrantes principalmente venezolanos
haitianos y colombianos en tránsito
hacia sus naciones de origen porque
somos muchos muchos padres y madres de
familia que estamos parados acá
durmiendo mal en esta situación pasando
frío este sol no es fácil estar parado
ahí esperando una respuesta en ese en
esa Resolana ni siquiera un toldo
estamos parados ahí como como inhumanos
estamos en humanos como me Disculpa la
expresión como perritos ahí parados este
viernes entró en vigor el estado de
emergencia de 60 días decretado por la
presidenta peruana Dina boluarte por el
que las fuerzas armadas brindarán apoyo
de vigilancia a los casi 400 policías
desplegados en la frontera Aunque El
Ejecutivo de Perú niega estar
militarizando la frontera con su vecino
chile la cancillería peruana estaría
trabajando con sus homólogos en Chile
Ecuador y Venezuela para la coordinación
de un posible corredor humanitario
terrestre o aéreo desde chile que
permite al retorno de los migrantes algo
con lo que también está de acuerdo el
gobierno chileno por su parte Lima
también aplicará una reforma migratoria
y un centro de regularización de los
migrantes en su territorio sobre los
ciudadanos extranjeros que permanecen en
la ciudad de tacna con toque ya conversó
con las autoridades locales para buscar
un lugar que sirva como albergue
Temporal y soporte humanitario a los
migrantes que permanecen en parques y
terminales terrestres distintas
organizaciones humanitarias piden la
creación de dicho corredor para paliar
la situación de los menores de edad
mujeres embarazadas que se encuentran
varadas en la zona fronteriza señalando
que las políticas criminalizatorias de
la migración han hecho invivible
permanecer en chile para estas personas
que ahora buscan retornar